This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《硬着头皮学》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都实在不安全、无法坦诚进行的对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就非得这么做，听听怎么学。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《硬着头皮学》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你在很大程度上两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探，才能揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名女同。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
这就是当电梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上的“2%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we are going to talk about romantic relationships
他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《女朋友们：相信我，宝贝》。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听我们的另一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析二十多岁的心理。今天，我们将探讨浪漫关系
in our 20s, specifically the question of why do we settle during this decade? Why do we date people? we know we shouldn't be with. Why do we accept less than we deserve? Why do we give people second chances, third chances, and cling on for too long, despite objectively being in one of the best times in our lives of our lives to be single and to be uncoupled and to be seeing kind of, you know, what's out there. Time and time again, I feel like I see people and I hear from people in these. mediocre relationships with, you know, individuals they don't even seem to like, and yet they are unable to leave, all because there is this deep fear that we have of being single forever, or of dying alone, of being alone day to day. And it's honestly a bit of a tragedy. But when we
在我们二十岁的时候，具体来说是这样一个问题：为什么在这个十年里我们会将就？为什么我们要和那些明知不该在一起的人约会？为什么我们接受的要比我们应得的少？为什么我们要给别人第二次机会、第三次机会，并且死死抓着不放太久，尽管客观上讲，这是我们一生中单身、未婚、看看外面世界的最好的时期之一？一次又一次地，我觉得我看到人们，也从人们那里听到，他们处于这些平庸的关系中，（你知道的）对象甚至似乎都不是他们喜欢的，然而他们却无法离开，这一切都是因为我们内心深处有一种对永远单身的恐惧，或者对孤独终老、日复一日孤身一人的恐惧。老实说，这有点像是一场悲剧。但是当我们的
have more life ahead of us than behind us, it seems almost strange that we continue to have this fear and that it is so powerful and impacting our decision-making so deeply. So I want to discuss it from a psychological standpoint, the pressures we face, the conflicts we have within us, and why we settle in our 20s. I would also kind of hope that this episode might just inspire you to re-examine your relationship at this pivotal point in your life. If someone isn't making your life better, every day isn't making you a better person every day, why stay with them?
未来的人生比过去的人生还要漫长时，我们继续心怀这种恐惧，并且让它如此强大、如此深刻地影响我们的决策，似乎就显得几乎有些奇怪了。所以我想从心理学的角度来讨论这个问题，我们所面临的压力，我们内心的冲突，以及为什么我们在二十多岁时会选择将就。我也某种程度上希望，这一集或许能激发你在人生这个关键节点重新审视你们的关系。如果一个人没能让你的生活每天都变得更好，没能让你每天都成为一个更好的人，为什么还要和他（她）在一起呢？
when arguably being single in your 20s is a whole lot better for your character development. I want us all to, you know, altogether kind of question why we have been asked to expect so much less from love than we should. And why, especially in our 20s, we've been asked to make compromises. There are so many factors behind this. I know like relationship anxiety plays a big role, but I do believe that there are a lot of people who are secretly very unhappy, and it stems from the inability to see our worth and what we deserve in our 20s. So hopefully, this isn't too much of a wake-up call for any of you. It's more so informative and something to think about, but without further ado, let's talk about why we settle in our 20s.
相比之下，可以说在二十多岁时单身对你的性格塑造要好得多。我希望我们所有人，（你知道的）一起来探讨一下，为什么我们被要求对爱情抱有比应得的少得多的期望？以及为什么，特别是在我们的二十多岁时，我们被要求做出妥协。这背后有太多的因素。我知道比如关系焦虑起着很大的作用，但我确实相信，有很多人私下里非常不快乐，而这源于我们在二十多岁时无法看到自己的价值以及我们应得的是什么。所以希望这不会对你们中的任何人造成太大的警醒。它更多是具有启发性的、值得深思的内容，但话不多说，让我们来聊聊为什么我们在二十多岁时会选择将就。
There is obviously not one way to live our lives during this decade, or one way to pursue love during this decade. I think I just need to acknowledge people have different values and different dreams and different needs in their life. You know, some people want to get married young. Some people, you know, find the one when they're younger. Some people are just happy to be single or just happen to find themselves single. But I will make one thing super clear. A guiding part of my life philosophy, specifically the philosophy I have for my 20s is it is not wrong to want being. grand, wonderful things for yourself. And during these years of your life, you owe it to yourself to chase after those things in every way that you can. That may apply to your passions, to your career,
在这个十年里，我们显然不是只有一种生活方式，也不是只有一种追求爱情的方式。我想我只是需要承认，人们在生活中有着不同的价值观、不同的梦想和不同的需求。你知道，有些人想早点结婚。有些人，（你知道的）在年轻时就找到了真命天子/天女。有些人只是乐于单身，或者只是碰巧发现自己单身。但我有一点要说得超级清楚。我生活哲学中的一个指导部分，特别是针对我二十多岁的哲学，那就是：想要为自己争取宏大、美好的事物，并没有错。在你人生的这些年里，你欠自己一个尽可能去追求这些事情的交代。这可能适用于你的热情、你的职业，
to your friendships, your big dreams, your dreams to travel to see the world. And it also majorly applies to love. This is such a sacred time in your life. And so settling now when you have the whole world in front of you is honestly, it's a disservice to yourself. And I kind of want to explain why. Firstly, though, we can't really get into that without examining, you know, what does it mean to settle in a relationship? What does it look like? To give you a simple definition, I think it means being in a relationship just for the sake of being in a relationship when your needs, your values, desires, deeper vision for love, is not being met. Now, this can be obvious, like when someone doesn't treat you right, is cruel, is mean, is uninterested, but it can also be
你的友谊，你的宏大梦想，你环游世界看世界的梦想。这也同样严重地适用于爱情。这是你生命中如此神圣的时刻。因此，当你面前有整个世界时，现在的将就老实说，是对你自己的不公。而且我想解释一下原因。不过首先，如果不先审视一下（你知道的）在一段关系中“将就”意味着什么，它长什么样，我们就无法真正深入探讨。给你们一个简单的定义，我认为这意味着仅仅为了恋爱而恋爱，而你的需求、价值观、渴望、对爱情更深层次的愿景并没有得到满足。现在，这可能是显而易见的，比如当某人对你不好、残酷、刻薄、不感兴趣时，但它也可能是
more subtle. It can be someone who does all the things that you'd expect or hoped they would, but who deep down you know doesn't fulfill you, who doesn't improve you, who doesn't excite you, but you stay because it's good enough because they're nice because they're fine maybe because you don't think that you deserve more or you will ever find more the question or the thing I always say to that is like you may never find better but is this even that good anyways you know of course every relationship has its doubts we need to talk about that more every relationship is going to have stress it's going to have problems that people need to work through you will not find a single relationship where people haven't had issues or miscommunications, but settling isn't about not
更加微妙的。它可能是一个人做了你期望或希望他做的一切，但你内心深处知道他并没有让你感到充实，没有让你变得更好，没有让你兴奋，但你留下来是因为“这就足够了”，因为他人很好，因为还过得去，也许是因为你认为自己不值得拥有更多，或者你永远找不到更多。对这个问题的疑问或我总是说的话是，你可能永远找不到更好的，但这段感情本身真的有那么好吗？当然，每段关系都有它的疑虑，我们需要对此进行更多讨论；每段关系都会有压力，会有需要人们去解决的问题。你找不到一段完全没有问题或沟通不畅的关系，但将就并不是指没有
having arguments. It's about your deeper core value needs, emotional needs, personality and compatibility needs. It's actually quite complex for a word that means choosing less than, but here are some kind of therapist-backed signs that this may be happening in your relationship. number one, you constantly question whether this is all there is, whether this is like the love thing that everyone's been kind of going on about. Number two, you are constantly trying to fix things about them or about the relationship and it never truly works. Number three, they're holding you back from things you really want.
争吵。它关乎你更深层的核心价值需求、情感需求、个性和契合度需求。对于一个意指“选择劣质”的词来说，这其实相当复杂，但以下是一些得到治疗师支持的迹象，表明你的关系中可能正在发生这种情况。第一，你不断质疑这是否就是全部，这是否就是每个人都在谈论的那种“爱”。第二，你不断地试图改变他们或这段关系，但从来没有真正起作用。第三，他们在阻碍你去做你真正想做的事情。
Number four, you find that one of the biggest reasons you can't leave is actually, just because you're scared of being single, not because you actually want to be in the relationship. Number five, your gut instinct keeps telling you something is wrong and has for some time, but you ignore it. The sixth sign that you are settling is you find yourself relying on others to fulfill your emotional needs and not this person. And number seven, you feel indifferent. And this is a huge one. I had a friend of mine say to me the other day at dinner, you know, the opposite of love is not hate, it's indifference. I think I've quoted that on the podcast before because it couldn't be more true. If you just don't even care anymore, if you sit there and wish
第四，你发现你无法离开的最大原因之一，其实仅仅是因为你害怕单身，而不是因为你真的想维持这段关系。第五，你的直觉不断告诉你有什么不对劲，而且这种感觉已经持续了一段时间，但你却忽略了它。你正在将就的第六个标志是，你发现自己依赖其他人而不是这个人来满足你的情感需求。第七个标志是，你感到冷漠。这是一个巨大的标志。前几天吃晚饭时，我的一个朋友对我说，你知道，爱的反义词不是恨，而是冷漠。我想我以前在播客中引用过这句话，因为它再真实不过了。如果你甚至不再在乎了，如果你坐在那里希望
that they'd break up with you, you are settling. Sometimes, you know, you don't find that you hate them. You just simply don't care. And that's a huge sign to me that the love and the life is gone. The irony is, is that we can mentally tick off everything on this lip. And and you can say, yeah, that's me, that's me, that's me, and yet again, find excuses for why that's maybe not you or why you will stay. What's really happening here is a form of cognitive dissonance. When we know we deserve better, but we still stay, what we do conflicts with what we continue to understand and believe.
他们跟你分手，那你就是在将就。有时候，（你知道的）你并不觉得自己恨他们。你只是根本不在乎了。对我来说，这是一个巨大的信号，说明爱和生命力已经消失了。具有讽刺意味的是，我们可以在精神上勾选这个清单上的每一项，你可以说，“是的，这就是我，这就是我，这就是我”，然而却又一次为为什么那可能不是你，或者为什么你要留下来寻找借口。这里真正发生的是一种认知失调。当我们知道自己值得更好的，但我们仍然留下来时，我们的做法与我们不断理解和相信的观念发生了冲突。
You know, we know that we aren't meant to be in this relationship, and yet we stay there, and that creates discomfort. And in that emotional place, we do tend to just linger and feel terrible until we do something. If you've never been in this situation, you know, you may not understand why that is. And even if you have, you may not know exactly why. So let's talk about some explanations. Psychologically, emotionally, socially, why do we settle? The first reason is that the relationship feels.
你知道，我们知道自己不该处于这段关系中，然而我们还是留在了那里，这带来了不适感。在那样的情感处境中，我们往往会纠缠不清，感觉糟透了，直到我们采取某种行动。如果你从未经历过这种状况，（你知道的）你可能不会明白为什么会这样。即使你经历过，你可能也不知道具体原因。所以让我们来谈谈一些解释。从心理上、情感上、社会上来说，我们为什么会选择将就？第一个原因是这段关系感觉
feels safe or good enough. The worst kind of relationship to leave is the one where when it's really good, it's really good. And when it's bad, it's really bad. Or when it's bad, you just feel nothing. This creates such intense emotional fluctuations that you just don't feel like you can pinpoint the truth. It makes it so much harder to exit the relationship because you're essentially, always anticipating when things might turn to be better. And you're secretly hoping for that. And so because there isn't this all-out sign or declaration that the relationship is bad, you continue to live on the hope of it.
安全或足够好。最难离开的那种关系是，当它真的很好的时候，好得无以复加；而当它糟糕的时候，又糟糕透顶。或者当它糟糕时，你什么感觉也没有。这会产生如此剧烈的情绪波动，以至于你觉得自己根本无法锁定真相。这让退出这段关系变得难得多，因为你基本上一直在期待情况什么时候会变好。而且你对此抱有秘密的希望。因此，既然没有一个彻底的信号或宣告表明这段关系很糟糕，你就会继续靠着对它的希望生活下去。
Hope will kill you. Hope kills us in these situations because we keep expecting the time when it's just all going to be good from now on. And we don't want to give up on that potential. on that future that we desperately want so badly. That's the thing about these situations. You want to be in this relationship. You just know it's not working. It also comes down to loss aversion.
希望会害死你。在这种情况下，希望会杀死我们，因为我们一直在期待那个“从今以后一切都会变好”的时刻。我们不想放弃那种潜在的可能性。放弃那个我们如此绝望地渴望的未来。这就是这些情况的症结所在。你想建立这段关系。你只是知道它行不通。这也归结于损失厌恶。
This is a psychological phenomenon that describes how we feel the pain of losing something that we had and something that we valued more so than probably anything else and we will do a lot to stop ourselves from, missing out or to stop ourselves from losing something, even if we don't actually typically
这是一种心理现象，它描述了比起其他任何事情，我们对失去曾经拥有的、曾珍视的事物的痛苦感受得更为强烈，并且我们会付出很多努力来阻止自己错过或阻止自己失去某样东西，即使我们实际上并不通常
see it as very valuable. There is this deep pain that comes from putting in so much time and energy and love and work into a relationship and it failing anyways. You can't say that you didn't try though. You can't say that you did not give it 100%. And that's the thing if work, And love was all it took. Well, then shouldn't it be working? But it's not. You also need other things. You need compatibility. You need communication. You need the spark. Another reason that we settle, especially in our 20s, is FOMO and the timeline trap. We see all these people around us in these relationships. And oh my gosh, don't they look like they're having so much fun? And they've really like found their person and they're so.
认为它很有价值。把那么多的时间、精力、爱和心血投入到一段关系中，结果它还是失败了，这种痛苦是极其深刻的。不过，你不能说你没有尝试过。你不能说你没有付出百分之百的努力。这就是问题所在，如果努力和爱就是全部所需，那么，难道它不应该起作用吗？但它没有。你还需要其他东西。你需要契合度。你需要沟通。你需要火花。我们选择将就的另一个原因，尤其是在我们二十多岁的时候，是FOMO（错失恐惧症）和时间表陷阱。我们看到身边所有的人都处于这些关系中。噢，天哪，难道他们看起来不像是玩得很开心吗？他们真的（比如）找到了他们的真命天子/天女，他们是如此
so happy and they do everything together and oh my god now they're engaged and now she's engaged and he's engaged and everybody's engaged and everyone's getting married and I'm going to be the last single friend and I'm going to be miserable. There is this intense milestone anxiety that is around every single corner in our 20s really that we are not where we should be. We are and do not have what we have that would potentially make us happy at this stage. And how could our lives begin? How could we move on unless we ticked this thing off our list. And so when you're in a relationship that feels good enough, you're sometimes the comfort of being able to say, oh, okay, I got that ticked off the to-do list, even if it's not very well done, is really all you're asking for. The thing is,
如此快乐，他们做什么都在一起，哦天哪，现在他们订婚了，现在她订婚了，他也订婚了，每个人都订婚了，每个人都在结婚，而我将成为最后一个单身的单身狗，我会很悲惨的。在我们的二十多岁时，每一个角落都弥漫着这种强烈的里程碑焦虑，即我们没有处于应有的位置。我们处于这个人生阶段，却没有那些本可以让我们快乐的东西。我们的生活怎么能开始呢？除非我们把这件事从清单上勾掉，否则我们怎么能继续前进呢。所以，当你处于一段感觉还不错的关系中时，有时候那种能够说“哦，好吧，我把待办事项清单上的那个勾掉了”的安慰，哪怕它做得并不是很好，也确实是你所要求的全部了。问题是，
is that, like, to use that to-do list analogy, you can do a terrible job and tick the thing off your list, but you know you did a terrible job, and you know you're still going to have to redo it. And that's the thing with this relationship conundrum you're probably finding yourself in. You've ticked the relationship off your list. To everyone else that might look great. Deep down, you know that you're not happy with the outcome. The fear of being single forever is another thing that comes up time and time again. It really sucks.
（你知道的）就像用那个待办事项清单的比喻一样，你可以把事情做得一塌糊涂然后把清单上的项目勾掉，但你知道你做得一塌糊涂，而且你知道你还得重做一遍。这就是你可能发现自己陷入的这段关系的困境。你已经把恋爱从你的清单上勾掉了。在其他人看来，这可能看起来很棒。但你内心深处知道，你对这个结果并不满意。永远单身的恐惧是另一个一次又一次出现的问题。这真的很糟糕。
Let's just acknowledge it. It really sucks to think that you're going to be alone for the rest of your life. it just does. You know what? There's really nothing I can say to that. Other than that fear is directly correlated to you, perhaps not making great decisions when it comes to who you're dating. The 2023 study found that when they examined why people settled,
我们承认吧。一想到要在余生中独自一人，就真的感觉很糟糕。事实就是如此。你知道吗？对此我真的无话可说。除了这种恐惧与你在约会对象方面的决策不佳直接相关。2023年的一项研究发现，当他们调查人们为什么将就时，
the biggest factor was that they were scared of being alone. And this is especially the case if you are quite anxiously attacked. Those with anxious attachment styles find it difficult to let go of unhealthy relationships because their need for belongingness can overpower their need for emotional fulfillment. That's really difficult to be holding these two things that you think should go together and yet you're finding that they sit apart. I want to belong and I want to be loved and I'm in a relationship. surely those things all go hand in hand.
最大的因素是他们害怕孤独。如果你的依恋类型相当焦虑，情况尤其如此。那些有焦虑型依恋风格的人觉得很难放手不健康的恋爱关系，因为他们对归属感的需求可能会压倒他们对情感充实的需求。要同时把握这两件你认为应该放在一起、却发现它们其实各不相干的事情，真的很困难。我想要归属感，我想要被爱，而我在恋爱中。这些事情肯定都是齐头并进的。
And you're probably finding that maybe they don't. You have to approach being single like you are going to be single for the rest of your life. And that, you know, you are never going to find anyone. And let yourself be in that worst case scenario. Let yourself truly believe it. And then realize that it's actually really not that bad. You know what the happiest group of people are? and I know you've probably heard this time and time again,
而你可能会发现它们或许并非如此。你必须像你将要在余生中保持单身一样来对待单身。并且（你知道的）你永远不会找到任何人。让自己处于那种最坏的情况中。让自己真正去相信它。然后意识到其实真的没那么糟糕。你知道最快乐的一群人是谁吗？我知道你可能已经听过很多次了，
it's like single people and especially women over the age of 60. So this whole myth that if you're not in a relationship at 20, you're going to be alone forever is firstly probably not true. And the myth that being alone forever is going to mean that you're miserable is definitely not true. That's something that we really need to like start talking about. Low self-esteem, I think, also pushes us to settle. And I think that's something that comes through
那就是单身人士，尤其是60岁以上的女性。所以“如果你在20岁时不谈恋爱，你就会永远孤独”这个神话，首先可能不是真的；而“永远孤独就意味着你会痛苦”这个神话，绝对不是真的。这是我们需要真正开始讨论的事情。我认为，低自尊也会促使我们选择将就。我认为这是贯穿于
with all of those previous factors we discussed, I think that sometimes you may think that you've tricked this person into falling in love with you and that you could never trick another person, that you are maybe not good enough. And so for someone who's not good enough, they should accept the good enough relationship, right? This is all you ever deserve. This is all you're ever going to find.
我们之前讨论的所有那些因素之中的，我认为有时你可能会觉得你骗了这个人让他爱上了你，而你再也无法欺骗另一个人了，你可能不够好。所以对于一个不够好的人来说，他们应该接受一段“还算过得去”的关系，对吧？这是你应得的全部。这就是你永远能找到的全部。
If you were to be single again, it's just going to be miserable and no one's going to find you attractive and no one's going to think you're hot, no one's going to think that you're intelligent or worth their time. That's ridiculous. I'll just call it out. I'm talking to the voice in your head right now. It's not true.
如果你再次单身，生活只会变得一团糟，没有人会觉得你有吸引力，没有人会觉得你性感，没有人会觉得你聪明或值得他们花时间。这太荒谬了。我直言不讳吧。我現在正是在对你脑海里的那个声音说话。这不是真的。
It's lying to you. But that lie is what's keeping you in a relationship that actually probably is worsening your self-esteem because you don't feel good about yourself. You're not able to act on what you want from your life. You're not happy. The final reason we settle is that we don't want to disappoint other people. this isn't another really hard one. Maybe your family really loves who you're with.
它在对你撒谎。但那个谎言正把你困在一段实际上可能在恶化你自尊的关系中，因为你对自己感觉不好。你无法按照自己对生活的渴望去行动。你不快乐。我们选择将就的最后一个原因是，我们不想让其他人失望。这又是另一个非常棘手的问题。也许你的家人真的很喜欢你的伴侣。
Maybe they think that he or she is amazing. Maybe they're all your grandparents can talk about. All your aunts and uncles want to hear about. Every one of your friends thinks they're great. Everyone's so happy and thinks you've got this beautiful relationship. Breaking up with them would be admitting that that was a lie. And you think that you might break other people's hearts in the process. They don't care.
也许他们觉得他或她棒极了。也许他们满嘴都是你的祖父母。你所有的阿姨和叔叔都想打听。你的每一个朋友都觉得他们很棒。每个人都那么高兴，觉得你们有这么美妙的关系。跟他们分手就等于承认那是个谎言。而你认为在这个过程中你可能会伤了别人的心。他们才不在乎呢。
They do, but they care in the sense that they want you to be happy. They want you to find and be in the relationship that just makes you feel incredible about yourself. If you were to truly talk to them and tell them about all the stuff that was happening in your relationship, or even if the relationship is good, all the things that you were feeling and how unhappy you were, they would want you to make the choice to leave. You know that. they're not going to be disappointed. But these are some of the reasons why we stay,
他们确实在乎，但他们是在“希望你快乐”的意义上去在乎的。他们希望你找到并处于一段能让你对自我感觉好到爆棚的关系中。如果你真的跟他们谈心，告诉他们你关系中发生的所有事情，或者即使关系本身还不错，把你所有的感受以及你的不快乐告诉他们，他们会希望你做出离开的选择。你知道的。他们不会感到失望的。但这些就是我们留下来的一些原因，
why we end up settling when we know deep down that we shouldn't. We're going to take a short break here, but when we return, I want to talk about the cost of this decision in the nicest way possible and where to go from here when you know the relationship isn't right. How do you leave it?
为什么当我们内心深处知道不应该将就时，最终还是选择了将就。我们在这里稍事休息，但等我们回来时，我想以最友善的方式谈谈这个决定的代价，以及当你明知这段关系不对劲时，接下来该何去何从。你如何离开它？
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
2%。这就是当电梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以抛开那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上具有炎症性。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-Heart Radio app,
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即i-Heart Radio应用上的TWA%，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush to do a little Kim. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
苹果播客，或任何你获取播客的地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMAs上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金有什么关系。好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这一关的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Marc Lamont Hill）的访谈，他滔滔不绝地谈论了80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊当天的快克，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿线了。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
我们现在还把艾滋病摆上台面了。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《硬着头皮学》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
为了响应心理健康意识月，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我指的是。特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person? because you're afraid.
而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的比赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯廷·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要。你是个好人吗？因为你害怕。
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地去做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《硬着头皮学》中，就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标进行真正的对话。
Open your free, our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that follow revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用。搜索《硬着头皮学》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法院听证会暴露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lespian and Michael Marantini.
你在很大程度上两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, so what is the cost to?
我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。好吧，那么代价是什么呢？
of settling in our 20s especially. That's the next big question we need to answer. If you're in a good enough relationship, and that is to you better than being single, which I understand why in many ways, you might just be thinking to yourself like, well, why can't I just stay a little bit longer? Like, this isn't that bad.
特别是我们在二十多岁时的将就。这是我们需要回答的下一个大问题。如果你处于一段“还算过得去”的关系中，而且对你来说这比单身要好——我理解为什么在很多方面会这样——你可能只是在想，嗯，为什么我不能再多待一会儿呢？比如，这其实也没那么糟糕。
Why not just, like, enjoy the security of this all for a little while, like while it lasts? Well, if you are scared about losing a good enough relationship, I need you to seriously consider how much else you are losing by staying in that relationship and everything else that you are missing out on. This is a good way to counteract our loss aversion by thinking about all the potential things that we are losing, the opportunity costs that we are losing by staying in this relationship. And that's an economics term to basically reference like if I gave you $5 and you bought an apple,
为什么不（比如）享受这一切的安全感一段时间，直到它消逝？好吧，如果你害怕失去一段还算可以的关系，我需要你认真考虑，通过留在那种关系中，你还失去了多少其他东西，以及你错过了什么别的东西。这是一个抵消我们损失厌恶的好方法，那就是去思考我们正在失去的所有潜在事物，即通过留在这种关系中而失去的机会成本。这是一个经济学术语，基本上是指如果我给你5美元，你买了一个苹果，
like essentially there is opportunity in your money and there is opportunity to also buy an orange and also buy a pear and also buy, I don't know, a banana. And you're not just spending the money you're spending or choosing the opportunity to spend your money on a certain thing. So the cost of settling falls across three categories. The identity cost, the obvious opportunity cost or romantic cost, and the experience cost. Let's start with the identity cost. Firstly, you may really struggle to be able to figure out who you are if you stay in a mediocre relationship. You become hide up in this other person. Of course you do. If you have begun to share a life with them, if you've moved in with them, if you've traveled with them, if you've shared friends,
（比如）本质上你的钱里蕴含着机会，也有机会去买一个橙子，去买一个梨，去买一个，我不知道，一根香蕉。你花的钱不只是你花的钱，或者选择把钱花在特定事情上的机会。所以，将就的代价分为三个类别。身份代价、显而易见的机会成本或浪漫成本，以及体验代价。让我们从身份代价开始。首先，如果你留在一场平庸的关系中，你可能会很难弄清楚自己究竟是谁。你和这个人紧紧纠缠在了一起。你当然会这样。如果你已经开始与他们分享生活，如果你已经同居，如果你和他们一起旅行，如果你分享朋友，
like if you do share friends with them, your relationship can be your epicenter. Everything revolves around it. And everything will continue to revolve around it, especially if you're worried about it ending because even more time and energy that you could be putting to yourself becomes fixated on like not trying to break up with them or like trying to quell your anxiety or make yourself feel better because you don't want to lose the history. You are spending and expending energy that could be better spent on yourself. It is a finite resource. Your 20s are, we already know this, the peak period of your life for identity exploration. Maybe only second to our teenage years, but I even think our 20s are more important because you have more independence
（比如）如果你和他们共享朋友，你们的关系就会成为你的震中。一切都围绕着它转。而且一切都将继续围绕着它转，特别是如果你担心它会结束的话，因为你本可以投入到自己身上的更多时间和精力，变得执着于“尽量不和他们分手”或“试图平息你的焦虑”或者“让自己感觉更好”，因为你不想失去这段历史。你正在花光和耗费那些本可以更好地用在自己身上的精力。这是一种有限的资源。正如我们已经知道的那样，你的二十岁是你一生中身份探索的巅峰时期。也许仅次于我们的青少年时期，但我甚至认为我们的二十岁更重要，因为你拥有更多的独立性
and a bit of money. You are meant to be trying on different versions of who you may want to be, like seeing what fits, seeing what doesn't fit, seeing where you want to live, what you want to try. You know, if you're with the right person, like, they will let you do that. They will allow you to be a separate entity and explore. They will actually probably expand your ability to do that and give you the freedom to discover yourself in a deeply fulfilling way.
和一点钱。你应该去尝试你想成为的各种不同的版本，看看什么适合，什么不适合，看看你想住在哪里，你想尝试什么。你知道，如果你和对的人在一起，（比如）他们会让你这么做。他们会允许你作为一个独立的实体去探索。他们实际上可能会扩展你这样做的能力，并赋予你以一种极具成就感的方式去发现自我的自由。
but with the wrong person, you experience something that we call identity for closure. This is a phenomenon whereby we basically choose who we are, and unfortunately we choose wrong, too early in life. And then we find ourselves so tied up in commitments and attached to this version of us that we just assume it's who we are because we like being this person. We're just like, oh yeah, this is of course me. I like being in this relationship. I like my identity as a girlfriend, as a husband, as a wife, as a partner, not because you
但如果和错误的人在一起，你就会经历一种我们称之为“身份提前闭合”（identity foreclosure）的现象。这是一种现象，即我们基本上在太早的人生阶段就选择了我们是谁，不幸的是我们选错了。然后我们发现自己被承诺绑得太紧，并依附于这个版本的自己，以至于我们想当然地认为这就是我们，因为我们喜欢成为这个人。我们只是觉得，“哦，是的，这当然是我。我喜欢处于这段关系中。我喜欢我作为女友、作为丈夫、作为妻子、作为伴侣的身份，”并不是因为你
actually do, but because you haven't looked at any other alternatives. You have foreclosed on the opportunity to explore. I had a friend who this happened to, and thankfully she has exited this relationship, but she started dating her ex when she was 17. By 19, they were living together. by 21, like I remember them planning their wedding. And I remember so much of who she was was this guy's girlfriend. Right after they broke up, because they did eventually.
真的喜欢，而是因为你没有看过任何其他替代方案。你提前关闭了探索的机会。我有一个朋友就经历过这种情况，谢意上帝她已经走出了这段关系，但她17岁时就开始和前任约会。到19岁时，他们已经同居了。到21岁时，（比如）我记得他们在筹划婚礼。我记得她的大部分形象都是这个家伙的女友。就在他们分手后——因为他们最终还是分了手。
And it took many, many years. I remember her being like, I couldn't even decide what to eat without him. I didn't have any hobbies that he wasn't involved in. I didn't have any real friends that didn't know us as a couple first. You know, I liked that I was a girlfriend and I liked that I was in a serious relationship because I think for her it made her feel mature. But the thing she said to me was like, I liked that experience, but I realized that I liked that experience more than I liked him.
而且这花了很多很多年。我记得她说：“没有他，我甚至连吃什么都拿不定主意。我没有任何他没参与过的爱好。我也没有任何不是先把我们当成一对情侣来认识的真正的朋友。”（你知道的）我喜欢我是一个女朋友，我喜欢我处于一段认真的关系中，因为我认为这让她觉得自己很成熟。但她对我说的话却是：“我喜欢那种体验，但我意识到我喜欢那种体验胜过喜欢他。”
She had experienced identity foreclosure. 17 was when they got together and because of the nature of their relationship, it was like she was kind of frozen, as she would say in her own words, like frozen at the point they became a couple. What we really want to be experiencing is what we call, identity moratorium. This is when a person is trying out roles or activities or different things in order to kind of trial and error into the most suitable one. And this process hopefully brings us to identity achievement. So this is when we find an identity we really like and our commitment
她经历了身份提前闭合。他们17岁时走到了一起，因为他们关系的性质，她感觉自己有点像被冻结了——正如她用自己的话说，“冻结在我们成为情侣的那一刻”。我们真正想要经历的是我们所说的“身份延缓期”（identity moratorium）。这是一个人的角色、活动或不同事情进行尝试和犯错，以便融入最合适的角色的时期。这个过程有望把我们带向“身份达成”（identity achievement）。所以这是当我们找到了一个我们真正喜欢的身份，并且我们对
to that identity is high because we have been able to go through and kind of cross out the things that we don't want to be because we have explored our options. Of course, you know, I feel like I have to make this caveat. We never really stop discovering. That's why you really need a partner at all ages who's going to let you explore on your own. But when this exploratory need is highest, confining yourself can be a lot more threatening. Settling in your 20s, and this may be controversial, but I believe it. It can also mean that you abandon your ability to find yourself through,
那个身份的承诺很高，因为我们已经经历过了，并且通过探索我们的选择，划掉了我们不想成为的东西。当然，（你知道的）我觉得我必须加上这个限定条件。我们永远不会停止探索。这就是为什么你在任何年龄都需要一个能让你独自探索的伴侣。但当这种探索需求最高时，自我禁锢可能会更具威胁性。在二十多岁时将就，这可能具有争议，但我是这么认为的。它也意味着你放弃了通过
the fun of meeting other people. Basically, you should be dating around. And some people don't agree with me and I totally understand why, but I think that being single truly brings so many opportunities to you know, figure out who you are through the lens of meeting other people and like having fun with them and determining what you like about them, what they like about you, what you don't like about them, what they don't like about you. I read this quote from Kristen Bell recently in which she was basically like, I wish I'd had more fun. I wish I'd butterflyed around more in my 20s. And even though I'm in a stable relationship now, I kind of have to agree with her. I had a lot of fun when I was single. Like, I wouldn't say actually fun. I had a lot of experiences. And I wish I'd had maybe a few more.
结识其他人来发现自我的能力。基本上，你应该四处约会。有些人不同意我的看法，我完全理解为什么，但我认为单身确实带来了很多机会，（你知道的）通过结识其他人的视角来弄清楚你是谁，（比如）和他们一起玩得很开心，并确定你喜欢他们什么，他们喜欢你什么，你不喜欢他们什么，他们不喜欢你什么。我最近读到克里斯蒂安·贝尔（Kristen Bell）的一句话，她基本上是说：“我希望我能玩得更开心点。我希望我在二十多岁时能像蝴蝶一样多飞一会儿。尽管我现在处于稳定的关系中，但我还是有点同意她的看法。我单身的时候玩得很开心。比如，我不会说其实是好玩。我有很多经历。而我希望自己能再多经历一些。”
Some people do just know, but for others, you learn through error. So if you've picked the first person and they're like kind of all right. Not giving yourself the opportunity to get heartbroken and explore may actually be costing you. Not every experience that is painful is bad. Sometimes they do actually teach you important lessons. You know, I always get people who are like, you know, if you're not dating to marry, you're dating to be heartbroken. Heartbreak sucks.
有些人确实就是心知肚明，但对其他人来说，你是通过错误来学习的。所以如果你挑了第一个人，而他们（比如）还算凑合。不给自己经历心碎和探索的机会，实际上可能会让你付出代价。并非所有痛苦的经历都是坏事。有时它们确实教会了你重要的课程。你知道，我总是遇到这样的人，他们会说，“（你知道的）如果你不是为了结婚而约会，你就是在为了心碎而约会。”心碎是很糟糕。
It's not the worst thing in the world. It is fertile ground for growth. and to allow you to redefine what you want out of a future relationship. Maybe this is another helpful reappraisal for those of you or those of us who are scared to leave a good not great relationship. It's never a loss to give something your all and to try with someone and for it to maybe not work out. It's not a loss. Of course we're aiming for true love, but sometimes the next best thing is a lesson. Finally, you lose the everyday opportunity to just be happy.
它不是世界上最糟糕的事情。它是生根发芽的肥沃土地，能让你重新定义你对未来关系的期望。也许这对你们中那些害怕离开一段“还不错但并非好到极点”的关系的人来说是另一个有帮助的重新评估。全力以赴去付出，和某人尝试在一起，而它可能没有成功，这绝不是一种损失。这不是损失。当然，我们的目标是真爱，但有时退而求其次最好的事情就是一个教训。最后，你失去了每天都能快乐的机会。
being in the wrong relationship, like your body feels that. Your mind feels that. You know. You feel sick to your stomach. You feel anxious all the time. You feel stressed, tense. There will be pain in leaving, of course, but that is a temporary pain versus the everyday chronic pain
身处一段错误的亲密关系中，你的身体会有所感知，你的内心也会有所感知。你知道的，你会感到胃部不适，会时刻感到焦虑，会感到压力重重、神经紧绷。离开自然会伴随着痛苦，但这只是一时的痛苦，相比之下，那种日复一日的慢性痛苦则是
of being in a place in a relationship that you don't belong. And every day you abandon yourself a little bit more. Every day you fall a little bit more silent. And every day you feel less like yourself, you feel less connected, you feel the resentment and numbness take over is a day you don't get back and is a day that you could have been spent healing. Not to scare you, but you have one precious life. You have to go after what you deserve and want. Even if right now you can't picture it, even if getting there means standing at the start of a marathon line
身处于一个本不属于你的地方、一段不属于你的关系中。每一天，你都在一点点地抛弃自我。每一天，你都变得愈发沉默。每一天，你都感觉越来越不像自己，越来越缺乏连接感，眼看着怨恨与麻木将你吞噬——这一天你再也无法追回，而原本这一天是可以用来疗愈的。并非为了吓唬你，但你只有这珍贵的一生。你必须去追求你应得的和想要的东西。哪怕此刻你在脑海中无法想象那个画面，哪怕抵达那里意味着站在马拉松的起跑线上，
and being like, I'm going to have to run through this and it's going to be really painful. at least you'll feel human rather than disappointment. At least you'll really know what it feels like to know yourself in the darkest points. So what do we do next? You've made the decision. It's a loaded question to ask, but where do we go from here? I will say, at this point, feels like a good time to just maybe propose a few more questions if you're still kind of uming and aering that might give you a little bit more information.
然后想着：我必须咬牙跑完全程，而且这个过程会非常痛苦。但至少，比起失望，你会感受到自己还是个活生生的人。至少，在那些最黑暗的时刻，你将真正懂得了解自己是一种什么样的体验。那么，我们接下来该做什么？你已经做出了决定。这是一个分量很重的问题，但接下来我们要去向何方？我想说的是，如果你现在还在犹豫不决、拿不定主意，那么此刻或许正是提出更多问题的好时机，这些问题也许能为你提供更多线索。
So before we think next steps, ask yourself these questions. If your best friend was in this relationship, what would you tell them to do? What would you in five years' time be begging you to do right now? If I gave you a guarantee right now that you would find someone else, would you stay with this person? When you picture your ideal relationship, is it the person you're with now who is in the these visions or not? These questions don't have a right or wrong answer. I think that's why they're so important. They're about tapping into your gut instinct. You know. And if maybe you're thinking this, you know, it could just be relationship anxiety, maybe, but relationship anxiety doesn't stick
因此，在思考下一步之前，不妨问问自己这些问题。如果你的挚友正处于这段关系中，你会劝他们怎么做？五年后的你，会恳求现在的自己立刻去做什么？如果我现在向你保证，你一定能找到另一个人，你还会和这个人在一起吗？当你想象自己理想中的伴侣时，现在的这个人会出现在这些幻想画面里吗？这些问题并没有标准答案，我想这也是它们如此重要的原因。它们触及的是你的直觉。你懂的。也许你会想，这可能只是恋爱焦虑罢了，也许吧，但恋爱焦虑可不会
around and stalk you for months. Relationship anxiety also is not unresponsive to any kind of changes. you know, it goes away when you talk to your friends about it. It goes away when you talk to your partner about it, when you're open about it. You know, we have a whole episode on how to tell the difference between intuition or anxiety that I would really recommend for moments like this. But, you know, sometimes you just have to do it and see if you feel better. So how are we going to try this? How are we going to leave?
持续数月并像幽灵一样纠缠着你。而且，恋爱焦虑通常会对各种改变有所反应。你知道的，当你和朋友谈起它时，焦虑就会消失；当你和伴侣开诚布公地谈论它时，焦虑也会消失。我们有一整期节目专门探讨如何分辨直觉还是焦虑，我非常推荐你在遇到这种时刻时去听一听。不过，有时候你就是得付诸行动，看看自己感觉会不会好一点。那么，我们该如何尝试呢？我们到底该怎么离开？
Number one, plan what you're going to say. I'm assuming that, you know, there's a lot of love in your relationship. There's just not a lot of compatibility or there's just not a lot of something he's missing, right? But I'm sure you still really care about them. Just plan out exactly your reasons. Talk about it in terms of you and what you need. Don't say like, oh, I think that you deserve better. No, just what do you need?
第一点，计划好你要说的话。我假设，你们的关系中其实有很多爱，只是缺乏足够的契合度，或者总觉得缺少了些什么，对吧？但我确信你依然很在乎对方。把你的理由一条条仔细规划好。从“你”的角度、从你的需求出发去谈。不要说“哦，我觉得你值得更好的人”之类的话。不，就只谈你需要什么。
Don't make promises that you're going to get back together. just make your dot points, maybe write them a letter, plan when you're going to do it, and then plan your next two weeks. Distract, distract, distract as much as you can for that first little chapter. This is when it's going to feel the hardest. I always say the first two weeks after a breakup and then the three month mark is when it's the worst. Those are like the hurdles that you need to get over. It will slowly get better.
不要许下会复合的承诺。列出你的要点，或许可以给对方写封信，计划好你打算在什么时候说出口，然后规划好接下来的两周。在前一小段艰难的时期里，尽可能地转移注意力、转移注意力、转移注意力。这段时间会感觉最难熬。我总是说，分手后的前两周，以及第三个月的时候，是感觉最糟糕的阶段。这些就像你需要跨越的跨栏。一切都会慢慢变好的。
Just plan out like what are. exactly you are going to do. Who are you going to see? What courses are you going to start? Get a gym membership. Like literally before you break up with this person, obviously like talk to them before, like and see if you can work stuff out. Like I'm kind of assuming that you've had some hard conversations before this. But if you really know you're going to do this, I need you to write down a timeline of what your next two weeks are going to look like. And I need all you. your evenings to be full. And I need you to know where you're going to be so that you don't just get stuck on the thought and just get back together. Get a project. This is good advice for any time.
只要规划好你究竟要做什么。你要去见谁？你要报什么课程？去办一张健身卡。就像在和这个人分手之前——当然，之前肯定要和他们谈谈，看看能不能挽回。我姑且认为在此之前你们已经进行过一些艰难的对话了。但如果你真的很确定要这么做，我需要你写下一份时间表，规划好接下来的两周会怎么度过。我需要你的每一个晚上都被填满，我需要清楚知道自己要去哪里，这样你就不会深陷于胡思乱想中，也不会轻易复合。找一个项目来做。这在任何时候都是很好的建议。
But have something that you can pour all of these feelings into, all of your grief, all of your loss. You know, even if you're the one to end things, like it's still going to be hard. Find something that you can channel that into to feel like you're making something from your pain. It doesn't have be creative, set a goal, set a task, set something you want to achieve, that's going to be the thing that you return to that you can just focus on, especially if it's something that brings you into a state of flow or something that you really wanted to like kind of get to in the past. Reflect on the lessons, not just the loss. A lot of time, and I think I've done this in the past, like I've suggested that you write a closure letter. I think it's better actually to tell
但是，找一件事情，把所有的情感、所有的悲伤、所有的失落都倾注进去。你知道的，哪怕你是提出分手的那个人，过程依然会很艰难。找一个能够宣泄这些情绪的出口，让你觉得痛苦也能转化为某种成果。它不一定要是创造性的，可以去设定一个目标、一项任务、一个想要达成的心愿，这将成为你的精神寄托，让你能够专注其中，尤其是那些能带给你心流状态、或者过去一直很想去实现的事情。反思其中的教训，而不仅仅是失落。很多时候——我想我过去也这么做过——我曾建议你写一封释怀信。其实我觉得，更好的做法是
the story of your relationship like it's a fable or like it's a very old story that has a lesson or a takeaway at the end. Someone always has to leave first, right? Why did you leave and what did you learn from the relationship? What are you bringing with you for this next chapter? When you apply and when you bring meaning to the pain, it doesn't make it any easier, but it makes it feel more important. And it takes away like the meaninglessness of it. Number five, my friend Gia actually gave was telling me about something that she did when she broke up with her partner which was that she found a single friend to kind of group up with like it's always so much easier to go through something when you're not going through it alone and she was like telling me
把你们的关系讲成一个寓言，或者像是一个古老的故事，在结尾处留下一个教训或启示。总得有人先离开，对吧？你为什么要离开？你从这段关系中学到了什么？为了接下来的新篇章，你随身带走了什么？当你去正视并赋予痛苦以意义时，虽然它并不会变得更轻松，但它会显得更加重要，从而消解了痛苦的虚无感。第四点，我的朋友贾（Gia）之前跟我讲过她在和伴侣分手时做的一件事：她找了一个同样单身的单身朋友抱团取暖——经历痛苦时，如果不是独自一人承受，总是会容易得多。她当时跟我说
about all these beautiful memories that they would have of like every night they would have their hot chocolate and they would like watch videos about how to desent to men and I was like that's that's really nice to have like a buddy um So find a community of people who are going through something similar. And also let yourself indulge in the bad feeling. Like, let yourself be sad. But also remember being sad has no correlation as to whether this person was right for you or not. You can feel devastated.
起他们那些美好的回忆：每天晚上他们会一起喝热巧克力，一起看视频研究怎么“驯服男人”。当时我就觉得，有个这样的死党真的太棒了。所以，去寻找一个有着相似经历的社群吧。同时，也允许自己沉浸在糟糕的情绪中。允许自己难过。但也要记住，难过与否，和这个人是否适合你之间没有任何必然联系。你可以感到心碎欲绝。
You can feel heartbroken and still know this wasn't right and was never going to be right. If you want to make your way through that feeling, don't run away from it. Let yourself just like be overwhelmed by it. watch La La Land, watch the notebook, watch the breakup, like get those movies ready, watch sex in the city, like have stuff ready so that you can just feel really, really sad. Have like your breakup album ready. The new Olivia Dean album is like an iconic breakup album. Like I think it would be an amazing companion for a recent split.
你可以感到悲痛欲绝，却依然明白这段关系并不对劲，而且永远也不会对劲。如果你想真正走过这段情绪，就不要逃避它。让自己彻底被它淹没。去看看《爱乐之城》（La La Land）、《恋恋笔记本》（The Notebook）、《分手男女》（The Break-Up），把这些电影准备好；去看看《欲望都市》（Sex and the City），把东西都准备妥当，好让自己能彻彻底底地难过个够。准备好你的失恋歌单。奥利维亚·迪恩（Olivia Dean）的新专辑简直是一张标志性的失恋神专。我觉得它会是近期分手的绝佳伴侣。
Like indulge in the feeling. Let yourself just really be sad. Let me finish by just making something abundantly clear. You are not being greedy or unrealistic if you expect or want an amazing love story for yourself. It is not unrealistic to want someone who makes time stand still, who completes you, who is undoubtedly your soulmate. That's not impossible. That is not asking for too much.
尽情沉浸在情绪中吧。让自己彻底难过。最后，我要用一句话来阐明一个毋庸置疑的事实，以此作为总结。如果你期待或渴望一段惊艳的爱情故事，你一点也不贪婪，也绝非不切实际。渴望一个能让时间停滞、令你的人生完整、毫无疑问就是你灵魂伴侣的人，这并不脱离实际。这并非不可能实现。这绝不是要求过高。
and you know you can call me a romantic but I believe fully that this is out there for everyone 100% I believe it no doubt in my mind but you cannot find that person if you are in a relationship that you settled for and I don't want you to be 50 60 waking up in bed beside someone realizing that the same feelings you have right now have always been there and you should have just listen to them right at the start. So I am sending you a lot of love. I feel like if you're listening to this, well, it's not for no reason. You probably know what you need to do and I know it's going to be really hard, but you are going to get through it. And in six months time, I see you absolutely thriving. Maybe in a year, but it will happen. So like take this information, do with it what you will,
你知道的，你可以叫我浪漫主义者，但我坚信这世上每个人都能拥有这样的爱情，100%坚信，我的内心毫无怀疑。但如果你身处一段将就的亲密关系中，你就绝对找不到那个人。我可不希望你到了50岁、60岁时，在某个人的身旁醒来，却突然意识到，你现在感受到的这种情绪其实一直都在，而你当初本该在刚开始时就听从内心的声音。因此，我向你们送去满满的爱。我觉得如果你正在听这期节目，那绝非偶然。你心里其实很清楚自己该做什么，我也知道这肯定会非常艰难，但你一定能熬过去。六个月后，我能看到你过得风生水起。也许是一年之后，但这一天一定会到来。所以，吸收这些信息吧，用你自己的方式去处理它，
but I'm sending you a lot of love, a lot of luck for this next chapter, whatever. you decide. I hope that you enjoyed this episode, maybe send it to someone that you think could benefit from it or just send it, re-listen to it, send it to yourself. If you are listening to this on Spotify or Apple, you may not know that we are also on YouTube. This episode is currently being filmed and recorded. So I don't know if you want to re-watch it since you've just finished, but if you want to watch other episodes, video episodes, you can go to our YouTube, the psychology of your 20s and follow us along there. You can also follow me on Instagram at that psychology podcast if you want to see
但我还是要为你接下来的新篇章送去满满的爱和好运，无论你做出什么决定。希望你会喜欢这期节目，不妨把它分享给你认为能从中受益的人，或者再听一遍，把它分享给自己。如果你是在 Spotify 或 Apple 上收听，你可能还不知道我们也有 YouTube 频道。这期节目目前正在进行视频拍摄和录音。所以，如果你刚听完还想再看一遍，或者想观看其他视频节目，可以前往我们的 YouTube 频道：The psychology of your 20s，并在那里关注我们。你也可以在 Instagram 上关注我：@that psychology podcast，如果你想看
behind the scenes and stuff that we're doing and stuff that we're working on. And if you want to contribute to episodes or suggest an episode, that's the place to do it. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself and don't ever settle. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
幕后花絮以及我们正在筹备和制作的内容的话。如果你想为节目投稿或建议节目主题，那也是个好地方。但在此之前，请注意安全，对他人友好，对温柔以待自己，永远不要将就。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，各位最近过得怎么样？欢迎收听 Learn the Hardway，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主播基尔·盖姆斯（Keer Games）。这个节目专注于黑人男性的生活经历，进行那些在其他地方根本无法坦诚展开的走心对话，而陪你聊这些的则是一位懂行的持证专业人士。有多少男人披上了厚重的盔甲？
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
这向世界传递了一个信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着，仅仅因为你拥有这种能力，你就必须时刻披荆斩棘。请在 AHA 广播应用、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听 Learn the Hardway。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控令两名女子怀上双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。“奥恩斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试结果两次，对吗？”“我伪造了一次测试结果。”这背后耗费了一大群互联网侦探，才终于揭开了一个令人不安的阴谋。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
另外两名经历过同样事情的男子——格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）也站了出来。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱的陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的推进，劳拉·奥恩斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。请在 IHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何平台上收听 Love Trapped 播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on. the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目 2% 中，我将剖析在当今这个奇特现代世界中培养坚韧意志、保持健康体魄以及建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，
That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
变成一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。请收听 2%。这就是 TWO percent，在 IHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何平台上都可以收听。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个劣迹斑斑的跨国骗子时，她们决定亲自动手讨回公道。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他绝不能就这样逍遥法外。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们常说，要相信闺蜜的话。请收听《闺蜜》（The Girlfriends）。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
相信我，宝贝。在 Iheart radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何平台上都可以收听。这是一档 IHeart 播客。保证由真人呈现。本集目前暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。